you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with diabetes this video will
show you what it is and why it's
important to keep it under control
people can have different symptoms with
diabetes common symptoms include feeling
very hungry
feeling very thirsty
urinating often
fatigue
blurry vision
and slow healing of wounds
people with type 1 diabetes may also
experience weight loss
symptoms of type 1 diabetes usually
develop suddenly they may make a person
feel very ill
on the other hand symptoms of type 2
diabetes usually develop slowly they may
be mild enough so they are hard to
notice some people have no symptoms
if your high blood sugar level isn't
treated life-threatening complications
can result for example you can become
severely ill with a condition called
diabetic ketoacidosis
it's more common in people with type 1
diabetes
here's how it happens because you have
little or no insulin in your blood your
cells can't get the sugar they need for
energy
as a result your body turns to fats and
proteins for energy
as your body breaks down the fats
certain substances known as ketone
bodies build up in your blood this
results in a condition called ketosis
if ketones build-up to dangerously high
levels in your blood you may develop
diabetic ketoacidosis or DKA this may
result in coma or death
if your blood sugar level drops too low
you may experience a serious
complication of diabetes called
hypoglycemia a common way this can
happen is by taking too much diabetic
medication or not eating too much
insulin or oral diabetic medication can
cause too much sugar to go into your
cells then your blood sugar level drops
down too low
certain organs such as the brain need a
constant energy supply to work properly
because the brain's main source of
energy is sugar it's the first organ
affected by lower sugar levels
when your brain cells called neurons
don't get enough sugar they start to
malfunction symptoms such as nervousness
shakiness and confusion can result
if your blood sugar keeps dropping your
brain does not have enough energy to
work properly this can result in
seizures or diabetic coma
if your blood sugar level remains high
over time long-term health problems can
occur they include heart and blood
vessel disease stroke
blindness nerve damage kidney disease
and amputation of a foot or leg
if you have questions about diabetes or
the medications for it
speak with your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor tell him or
her about any side-effects you have